[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the captain of the
seventh at least sins the dragon sin of
wrath Mele Otis in particular we will
examine the two drastically different
sides of melioidosis character the
fun-loving and lighthearted owner of the
bore hat bar versus the incredibly
dangerous warrior who is known for
losing control of his immense power and
causing devastating damage to everything
around him we will be delving deeper
into melioidosis character backstory and
his powers and abilities in order to get
the full picture of meliodas and in
order to understand why he is so
important for the entire story of the
seven deadly sins if you enjoy the seven
deadly sins content on this channel be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell and if you want to share your fan
art with us or maybe ideas for future
videos be sure to follow us on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar now this
video does contain manga spoilers
because it would be impossible to give
you the full picture of melioidosis
character without going into the
material from the manga so if you are
not caught up you have been warned but
if you are caught up or you just don't
care about spoilers then let's get into
it
Mele Otis is the first member of the
seven deadly sins that we meet in the
anime and manga and episode one of the
anime hooked me instantly into this
series because I loved the twist at the
end of the episode when we realized that
this childish an innocent-looking guy
who looks nothing like his wanted poster
is actually Mele Otis captain of the
seven deadly sins as the story goes on
we learned at meliodas is a member of
the demon clan and in fact he is the
eldest son of the demon king and the
former leader of the elite demon
warriors known as the ten commandments
meliodas was once a cruel and ruthless
demon and that dark side of meliodas the
demonic side comes out a number of times
as the story progresses
especially when someone Mele Otis cares
about is in danger when he sees someone
that he cares about suffering Mele
loses control his rage consumes him and
his demonic power destroys everything in
sight in fact sixteen years before the
start of the story the entire kingdom of
Danah form was destroyed when meliodas
exploded with rage after witnessing the
death of Liz the woman he loved so it
makes perfect sense that meliodas would
be the dragon sin of wrath now many have
made the argument that millie Otis's
peaceful fun-loving and carefree
personality is just an act that he puts
on in order to control his emotion so
that he doesn't go berserk however I
disagree with this claim
I believe that Mellie Otis has two
distinct sides to his personality both
are real they are not an act but they
are definitely in conflict with each
other and this conflict is one of the
defining plot points of the entire seven
deadly sins story if we look at the time
Mellie Otis spends with Liz even before
the destruction of Danna four we see the
meliodas is a calm peaceful and
fun-loving guy with a sense of humor Liz
fell in love with him in part because of
these character traits
Mellie Otis is not pretending to be this
person he is this person but there is
also a darker side to him which comes
from his demonic nature for instance if
Mellie Otis truly had no emotions that
he just pretended to be a normal guy to
keep his demonic powers at bay he would
not lose control when someone he loves
is in danger he loses control because he
has strong feelings for Liz and for
other people close to him so the fact is
that Mellie Otis is both a good-natured
kind heart and fun-loving guy and a
demon with a dark core that is always
threatening to consume him you probably
think of yourself as a normal person who
likes to joke around and have fun to do
nice things with your friends and family
and so on but if God forbid you were
ever put in a situation where someone
close to you is in danger where someone
you love is suffering your character
would probably change you would do
anything in your power to help the
person you love even things that might
be considered immoral or evil because at
the end of the day most people will do
whatever it takes to protect their loved
ones and they will do it regardless of
the consequences if someone does
something bad to you or to your loved
ones you would want to stop them or even
get revenge on them and many people in
the real world get consumed by feelings
such as revenge this is why Mele Otis's
inner conflict is so powerful it speaks
to human nature and the internal
struggle that all of us face of course
the seven deadly sins is a fantasy and
meliodas is literally a demon so that
conflict is more visible and extreme but
a similar type of inner struggle is
often present in each and every one of
us many characters in the seven deadly
sins have such rich and powerful
backstories and this is in my opinion
one of the greatest strengths of this
series who we are depends in large part
on where we come from and the reason
that the characters in this series are
so well developed is that their
histories and backstories are so well
thought-out melioidosis backstory in
particular is absolutely amazing and
heartbreaking over 3,000 years ago Mele
Otis was the favorite son of the demon
king and he was set to inherit the
throne of the demon clan and become the
next demon king himself however
everything changed when meliodas fell in
love with a member of the goddess clan
the demon and goddess clans are natural
enemies so the only way that meliodas
could be with the woman he loved was if
he betrayed his own clan abandoned the
ten commandments and escaped together
with the goddess he loved in the process
of escaping Mele Otis allegedly killed
two members of the ten commandments and
for the sin of falling in love with a
goddess and turning against his own kind
Mele Otis was condemned as a traitor
the goddess meliodas loved was also
treated as a traitor by her clan
although this may not be the whole story
from what we know so far Mele Otis's
decision to abandon the demon clan left
the demons vulnerable the balance of
power between the demons and the other
clans was disrupted and the goddess clan
along with the other races saw this as
their chance to finally defeat the
demons and the holy war
at some point the demon king and the
supreme deity who is the ruler of the
goddess clan attacked meli otis and his
lover and killed them for their betrayal
but not only that both of them were
cursed the demon king cursed meliodas so
that he would stop aging and so that he
couldn't die every time he was killed
Mele Otis would simply come back to life
with the additional caveat that every
time le Otis came back to life he would
lose some of his emotion which makes it
even harder for him to control his inner
demonic power the supreme deity cursed
meliodas has lovers so that every time
she died she would be reincarnated as a
human every time she is reincarnated she
loses her memories of Mele Otis but in
every lifetime she is still destined to
meet meliodas and fall in love with him
over and over again not only that but if
she ever regained her memories and
remembered Mele Otis and her past lives
that she spent together with him the
curse made sure that she would die three
days after regaining her memories
basically Mele Otis was destined to see
his lover to woman he loved died in
front of him over and over again for all
of eternity and he was powerless to stop
it in the name of this lover this
goddess that fell in love with a demon
is Elizabeth Princess Elizabeth Leona's
is the 107th reincarnation of the
goddess Elizabeth the woman that Mele
Otis loves and of course Liz Mele Otis's
previous lover was the 106th
reincarnation of the goddess Elizabeth
when Liz was killed by the demon fraud
Rijn sixteen years earlier meliodas lost
control his rage consumed him and he
destroyed the entire kingdom of Dan
afore as a result because of this Merlin
was forced to seal away most of
melioidosis power but once the ten
commandments are revived meliodas has no
choice but to get back his power just so
he would stand a chance of defending the
world from the ten commandments this is
the point in the story that season two
of the anime is really focusing on and
in fact episode 9 of season two is an
incredibly important episode for
understanding the conflict within
meliodas
in order to get back his power
from the Druids melioidosis put through
a test in which he has to relive the
death of Liz
Elizabeth's previous reincarnation over
and over again
he has to keep doing this keep reliving
this tragedy until he learns to control
his anger we see that on the one hand
millie otis really wants to be the
fun-loving and carefree character we
know he really just wants to live in
peace and be happy with Liz aka
Elizabeth
but the curse keeps destroying
everything he cares about and this
terrible emotional torture that he has
faced for 3,000 years pushes his demonic
core to the boiling point until he just
can't take it anymore
just imagine what Mellie Otis is going
through the person that he loves the
most in the world the person that he
sacrificed everything for keeps dying
before his eyes over and over again and
despite his amazing power as a warrior
he is still powerless to do anything
against this curse just imagine how
tortured melioidosis soul must be how
much suffering he has gone through for
3,000 years at one point in the manga
bond complains about having to see
Elaine the woman he loves died in his
arms without even realizing that
meliodas has had to go through this same
thing 106 times already and if you think
oh well it doesn't matter because this
same person keeps reincarnating over and
over again you have to remember that
although the soul of the goddess
Elizabeth keeps transferring into all of
these different people they are still
their own person each reincarnation has
her own unique experiences her own
unique personality and when she dies
meliodas still loses them forever in
some way this must be the worst kind of
torture something you wouldn't wish upon
your worst enemy and yet despite
everything meliora still wants to be a
fun-loving guy he wants to have friends
he wants to run a tavern where he makes
terrible food he just wants to be happy
this is exactly what I'm talking about
when I say that the seven deadly sins
has some of the most interesting complex
and well-developed characters in anime
and of course Mellie Otis is the perfect
example of that the goal and purpose of
Mellie Otis's entire journey that has
lasted for over three millennia is to
break the curse and end the cycle of
life and reincarnation that continues to
torture him and Elizabeth as the manga
progresses Valley Otis has to face some
incredibly difficult choices including
letting go of all of his emotions and
his sense of right and wrong as well as
potentially betraying his best friends
the seven deadly sins in order to gain
enough power to finally break the curse
it is an unbelievable exciting and
treacherous journey that still continues
in the manga and the more I research the
story and the characters of the seven
deadly sins the more videos I make on
this series the more I love and
appreciate it let me know what you guys
think do you agree with me that Mele
Otis is a brilliant character whose
inner struggle speaks to a fundamental
aspect of human nature that all of us
can relate to and would you like to see
me make more videos like this one
focusing on other seven deadly sins
characters like Eskin or Bondi and
Merlyn King and so on please give me
your requests and feedback on Twitter
and Instagram you can find us at anime
uproar if you enjoyed the seven deadly
sins content on this channel and you
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell and if you
want to know more about Mele Otis's
demonic powers his sacred treasure lost
Lane and that type of thing feel free to
check out our every member of the seven
deadly sins explained video that
particular video covers all of that info
so if you want to check it out I will
link it at the end of this video and
also in the description as always thank
you all so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]